like conflicting because he was like
it's just very conflicting because i'm
multi like this is just
party mary but this is not real life
mary's it's just weird i don't
it's just one that who's real life mary
really mary is just
a boring piece of [ __ ] that stays
laying in bed and then just periodically
gets up to paint and [ __ ] nurtures
her animals
this mary does not exist so it's just
wild
that's why i don't get offended because
it's
like a really bad
acid trip so i just can't come out it's
like i don't care i don't know there's
no words so who is the real mayor you
you grew up where the real mary
grew up everywhere
she was born in dukes la gutierrez
mexico
and her
her
family her dad they had like this um
in san cristobal and mexico they had
like this like um
what do you call it like oh honestly i
don't even know
something where it's like they're
helping like the
the native people of the land like
why don't you want to i don't because i
don't know but they they just had some
sort of
shelter and help for them and
like then he turned to a pastor for a
lot of his life and it was
a lot of kumbaya [ __ ] but
how would you describe your childhood
i
am kumbaya
what's [ __ ] fake
they're fake wow like i love it like i
know um
my dad he's fake he's [ __ ] fake as
[ __ ]
i know my mom literally loves me and
she's just like women are normally well
i can't say that cause like i cancel
it's like
it's more
anyway she was more passive whatever
and what i know she
has always loved me and she has proved
that to me with actions and
of all the humans in this world that
exist right now on this planet my mom
and my stepdad a thousand nosy like
literal zero doubt
love me
and dust and loves me and i know like my
brothers love me they everyone accepts
you as you are
and that's why
because i'm allowed to take care of a
girl
they love me
they [ __ ] love you
they [ __ ] rhyme for the [ __ ] hope
they love me so when did you start
modern uh perfecting modifying what you
were gonna call your
your body um and face
well that's what's like what like i love
how i'm like a vanvo queen whatever but
it's like
i
i just view it as this simple you know
it's like i literally just
i'm a human being that exists on this
planet that
literally just like surgery and it's
like you know how some human beings like
prefer
being blonde or prefer having black hair
or like like it's just something that's
simple in my mind where it's like i
literally actually don't overthink it
it's just i literally i'm like
well
like i want a bigger ass i'll try this
and then
like my actual real life is extremely
boring so then i'll be like
well i'll i might as well travel and do
this and like because it makes me happy
you know but it's like not
a thing where it's like oh my god i
think i need this done i need that done
it's a lot of it just comes from
impulsiveness and just wanting
excitement in my life
are you adhd
well i i don't believe in psychiatrists
and all that i would
never do that because i feel like if any
human being in this planet went to
a psychiatrist
every we're all [ __ ] up
every psychiatrist would tell us
there's something wrong with us so like
i don't want to fit myself in a label
and feel sorry for myself say oh well
this is wrong with me so i need this i
need that i'm i'm very i'm very i wake
up every day striving to be a better
human being and that is i don't need a
label for anything i strive to be a
better human in general except when i'm
a drunk piece of [ __ ] which is literally
only when i travel
which is literally like i'm not a
citizen of this [ __ ]
um
country so it's like there's i literally
only have six months here if that which
is actually less so it's just i'm
actually extremely normal
and then extremely messy half the time
but that's why like no words hurt me
because i know who the [ __ ] i am i love
it
when you when you look
at yourself in a mirror what do you see
that girl
i see when i look at myself in the
mirror i'm just
like i just i i feel i just recently
discovered this
um
sexuality and it's called autosexual
and it sounds so ridiculous so dumb but
to me it's actually
[ __ ] cool as [ __ ] because it's like
okay so like autosexual basically means
like where you're
in love with yourself but like
i know that could be perceived as like
narcissistical behavior but like to me
it's not to me it's like [ __ ] special
because it's like it shows honey you
don't need anyone [ __ ] you you [ __ ]
you you're born in this world alone
you die alone i've everyone even your
[ __ ] family
even your family is [ __ ] fake your
pets can be fake my cats i have of all i
have uh what like i have a pig
two cats and
five dogs they're all of them are fake
except for four and like you could see
you could feel the energy of who's
actually not fake so it's like at the
end of the day i know that
who is there for me you know what i mean
so it's just
well what are we talking about i forgot
about this
i was just saying when you look at look
at yourself in the mirror what do you
see
do you like what you say do you think
you're yeah when i when i look in the
mirror i feel
really good i feel um you're very
beautiful
in person especially i feel very
satisfied out like when i look at myself
in the mirror and that's what my
brothers always tell me
they're like
like they like that like mary
the character of mary because mary
doesn't actually exist
mary's just
married like i don't know how to explain
it's like you have to something you have
to experience in person
mary's mary like the character of mary
doesn't actually exist but i'm glad the
character of mary inspires people but
mary is actually a [ __ ]
human being that feels very very deeply
that loves very very deeply and like
like all i want i have good intentions
and maybe like
my chaoticness
comes out intense but i i really want
the good for everyone i don't care to
have a long life
and amazing life i just want good like i
like genuinely literally that's like
all i
ew
that's i don't care
oh my god is your life chaotic
but i don't think that's a bad thing i
think like when i cry i cry a lot i'm
emotional but i don't
think it's a bad thing it's just
real you feel
when you're a human being you feel [ __ ]
and i'm have a low education i don't
speak the best so like when like when i
feel it's real and like my emotions are
real how far did you go to school
i stopped going to school when i was in
well i don't know maybe like grade 9
grade 10 i never really actually went to
school so it's like but that's why i
feel like um
i am a giant div [ __ ]
school wise but i i feel like way
smarter wise than like
normal people could i just feel i have
really good life experience so like i
feel like superior in a way because i'm
like
the way i experience my reality as a
human is like
you can't make a mark
you really actually can't make this [ __ ]
up it's just so wild it's like
it's wild it's like i i'm just
realized this is everyone has their own
reality tunnel so i i just don't get
offended by anything because i know like
my intentions and like that everyone
doesn't have that
luck to be like
have that security of who they are or
what life is whatever i've just
had a long life honey
have you been in love before what have
you been in love before
yeah
and i love it i'm in love with um
there's love there's in love and there's
infatuation right now i'm currently
have the love feeling but i have felt
all sorts of those i have felt
infatuation
i have felt in love and i have felt love
love is unconditional and beautiful and
amazing and
i feel like that's more long term and
love is kind of like infatuation but in
love is more like
i want to ride
it's literally just more like
you want to love you think you love the
human but it is kind of unconditional
jealousy this but like i feel love right
now yeah i have a human right now that
is not related to me that i will
literally just be there for
forever
i don't like that he's gave a [ __ ]
i would be there for him forever i don't
care would you describe yourself as
happy you seem happy
i don't think that exists no i feel like
i used to always be like ew i like
people used to always now see they're
like oh well
what does happiness mean to you like are
you there and i used to be like oh my
god in life does he have you shut off oh
it's just so big right now like
i really feel
it's it's not a destination happiness
comes in waves so at one point in life
you're gonna be happy but it's not
possible to just stay there and also
it's like humans we always just want
more
and more and even if you're [ __ ] my
daddy you almost own a rat owner
you think he's happy ambitious
he's
he's a real special
girl like it's like everyone's just
gonna want more and it's like you could
be in in general yes i'm happy like i
have not experienced depression that's
why i feel just
like maybe i'm not the perfect human to
the world but it's like i'm just so
proud and happy in myself because
comfort i used to actually be suicidal
depressed and i have not felt that
emptiness feeling
for like four years now so i like that
just proves i've grown as a human and
it's like that's why it's just
everything is just so subjective in life
so you literally cannot even like
get mad at
anyone even when they think matt like
badly of you or this or that
then their mind that is true do you
understand it's just a giant you have to
do mushrooms honey
are drugs are drugs a part of your life
i want to ride
no i wouldn't say
no i wouldn't i would say
mushrooms
dab a girl
if it wasn't for like mushrooms really
they smoked something in me which i knew
i always had but also more but it was
more of like
i never did mushrooms to like party i
was just i knew when it was given to me
was like spiritual whatever and but yeah
i definitely like
and you can do mushrooms and they'll see
that it's
you just i don't like i don't even know
i'm not the english scholar so i'm not
going to talking but yeah mushrooms yes
it changed me a lot but also like
other than that i don't
i don't condone drug use i've done
propers for a week and i loved it but
i don't like i just drink and i i don't
even actually drink i just drink when i
travel when i'm at home this persona
does not exist so that's why it's
confusing when people are like
oh
you're mentally unstable
i agree
rebuke me honey because like this is
this mary is not even an actual person
do people come up to you when they meet
you and think you're just nuts
because of your body modifications
they actually just kiss my ass
tell me what you've had done you've had
a lot a lot of work done so the body
modifications i have had done was my um
well where did i begin i don't know i
had blood implants
i've had
blood injections multiple times i've had
three
brazilian butt lift procedures i've had
injections
on my legs i've had um
i lift i've had brow live multiple times
i've had um
i've had um
your dresser my oh yeah i've had my soul
i'm just guessing yeah i've had my my
boobs done
six times
and i've had expanders now so it's like
you could just keep filling it
with my vagina done three times which i
almost died yes i have the fattest [ __ ]
in the world like literally actually
scientifically yes
and i've had my
lips done multiple times teeth and
multiple times well it's just so much
just like hard to actually i'm probably
missing a lot but
you look like you were probably very
beautiful before you started all this
i'm sorry i'm beautiful now but it's
like it's different types of videos and
also beauty subjective so when people
say that to me it's like shut up
it's like girl okay i was very beautiful
then but also
i got rich after so
so
like yes kumbayas you know natural and
that's the thing i think all types of
women are viewed i would not
recommend everyone to have
an extreme type of look just because
well i just kind of think it's normal
too when you're
everyone fantasizes about a different
life so yeah of course sometimes i
fantasize about being like a normal girl
with no surgeries going to college being
very late
and i think that's normal what do you
think what do you think is behind your
desire to
do so many modifications to your body
well
that's just so crazy are you looking for
love or are you looking for literally
literally not
i was a stripper i was down for the show
there's nothing i literally
that's what's wild
everyone always looks for like
a deep meaning of why
i did the things i did and it's
there is not and it just sucks to breaks
people heart and like think of like this
thief like sadly like oh mommy i'm
scared was there anything in your
childhood that might
be what you're running away from
no
no viewers oh my dad's [ __ ] has
nothing to do with i have daddy issues
you haven't like i literally it was
literally just simply like when when i
saw
um there was two girls that everyone
would always talk [ __ ] about in the club
and they had some big ass
and i just was like oh my god they look
so hot and i loved it and then it like i
guess it kind of initiated from there
but i've always
known i want surgery but there was
nothing like
it's not a deep-readed deep-rooted issue
it's like
oh my god i'm so scared like you know
what i mean is it like an addiction
i mean from a normal human standpoint
an addiction i mean do you drink coffee
i do do you smoke no
oh shut up
okay hypothetically allegedly another
human do they drink coffee do they do
yeah a lot of stream sports do they do
that like yeah we all do something we
all do something and and that's what
it's
it's just this is not viewed as normal
and
it's not i'm not defending it because
it's it's obviously unhealthy i don't
feel insecure about saying that
it can be unhealthy but i also just
think it's so hypocritical
because
girl everything else is too
so that's actually it's that's why i say
it's like a giant like [ __ ]
wild acid trip because it's like i have
learned so much from looking like this
literally literal fuckingly
from humans or everything so it's like i
i just feel as the all the bad and good
that's came from i just feel way more
wise because it's i'm sure you've
learned some very interesting things
what kind of things have you learned
because of this lifestyle that you live
i just definitely feel like it's
a we live in a world where it's like
the [ __ ]
and that we live in a world it's like
oh my god
body positivity
let's love everyone let's accept
everyone
as long as they look how they want you
to look it's fake this is what i've
i've learned that everyone
everyone is just so fake and it's like
at a point anymore i used to maybe cry
about it sometimes and like still stuff
like that but it's like i've reached a
point where i can't even laugh it's
pure comedy to me at this point where
you just can't make this [ __ ]
it's just wild like everything is wild
and
you know it's okay i don't i don't feel
like a victim i don't feel traumatized i
feel actually very blessed that you know
god has given me this very unique life
experience
where i'm able to just really
um observe all
humans and
actually
you know from like a front front world
point of view view view things reality
not a sugar-coated view of the world
and i feel good about it and not only
that like as as as
negative as the general shape may be i
feel very happy because i was very
depressed for a very long time literally
suicidal thought i would kill myself by
the end of 30.
i just feel like very like
i just feel very happy that like
i'm like
and i'm not like i wouldn't say i'm like
i'm good i'm not even like sad i guess
it's just like happy truth i'm not i
don't feel like
like set like whenever i feel like
sad about like the world and like
the way things are i just also feel like
super grateful that
that god or like whatever is god to
everyone because like in my opinion like
all uh buddha like it's all work it's
the [ __ ] same show
so i just feel like super blessed that
actually like
you know he gave me maybe things aren't
happening at the pace that i want them
to
but i'm still super grateful that i'm
able to [ __ ] like
you know
um have my animals my art a beautiful
[ __ ] house like you know what i mean
i'm
he he made me just stop having to
[ __ ]
i was escorting and stripping before and
i felt like a prisoner and it was just
so horrible and like
it is just like i'm just so grateful
that i
hallelujah for only fans
because girl
it did it helps so much people and like
girl i'm just like i just feel whenever
i'm actually like feeling sad i don't i
feel like that's why i don't actually
feel depressed anymore because i just
feel
so grateful generally seeking of
everything it's like
it's wild that this is my reality but
like in a good way but chaotic way but i
feel
grateful i feel like god is
going through something putting me
through this what i feel like he means
well
what are you afraid of what do you worry
about
i don't know i feel like i have no um
that's a good question
i don't fear death anymore i i was
watching this documentary about what i
think was i don't know if i'm saying
mark because your name's not i forgot is
it something toe something has last
names to i don't know but it's about the
simulation theory and that's why i was
in love with elon musk because he always
talks about that and everyone just
thinks it's like
so ridiculous
especially after my
you can't make this [ __ ] up i don't know
i guess
if i'm worried about anything it's
i just okay no i i guess i'm not i don't
have real fear i guess my real fear
would be that
uh of my animals i want to
be a good mother to them and i will
do my best to do that i just want good
for all of us and think of all of our
futures
and
we all have to be considerate of what's
going on and that's what i want for all
of us
beautiful
do you have any regrets in your life
i don't we all good girl
[Laughter]
but it's
it's just wow
everything just turns to like a wild
like mushroom
regrets
like i feel like um
like planet earth is just extremely
ghetto
and well i don't know if normal people
experience that i don't know
i just want i don't [ __ ] know but i
know that um
like there are obviously
things in life i would not
want to have done
but i feel like
i don't know i feel like the older you
get every year the fastest you really
like
realize that
you know regardless of the [ __ ] life
is not so bad and
in the sense where it's like for me
personally in hindsight all the
tragedies that have happened to me in
hindsight i see how they connected and
like i feel like any any human being i
could stay here and drown in my misery
and be like sad about stuff
but no i'm not gonna do that and i'm
going to just [ __ ]
try wake up every day and then if if if
i'm like i was a drunk yesterday that
made me feel like a piece of [ __ ] i need
to stop the next day i'm gonna be sober
if i'm like
you know i hate how i talk to this
person i love i'm gonna stop doing that
it's just all like life is not about
making yourself a victim life is about
just trying to be the best human you
could be so that when you die you die in
peace because at the end of the day
everyone could be atheist everyone could
be this stopped but no one really knows
where we're gonna go and all of us at
the day although we can deny it we're
all kind of scared of death in a way and
we just need to know that you know we
just as long i promise you any religion
you [ __ ] have any religion
just
wake up
you'll live your life and just try to be
the best human you can be
that's it that's what i think
i know well no because i'm very
passionate i really mean
you're much wiser than i thought you
were
i know and that's why i'm like i'm a
badass
so a lot going on here honey
why ask i had to go on
you know i'm desperate to talk you know
i love talking yeah you're doing great
you're doing great shut up mark
what's been the
the lowest point in your life
um
um
okay so the lowest part of my
my mark
the lowest point in my life
well i have like literally like three
highlights of like the really bad
moments
one was when like
oh my god ew
girl
[Music]
well i don't know i guess
i've had a wild ride as a human
experience like
i guess like
like the highlights of it like the
one of the bad ones like i had a pimp
and then i was just so over it i'm like
i just felt like literally like
i just felt like literally actually like
nothing like
like just like this
being that is here but like their their
soul wants to be alive but it's just
like
totally extremely gone and like wanting
to be happy and like
do good you know but it's like i i
didn't
know anything but that life whatever so
then i was like you know
i um
and he was i was just so sick of like
working for him and it's like i didn't
even love him but i just
like clung on to that because i was like
i don't know
you know i was desperate
a lot of women
girl a lot of women get into those kind
of relationships yeah but anyways and
like i just remember
one time it was in canada actually
and
yeah i like i just remember sending like
a suicidal text like my mom
and my brother and like
i just remember like getting i got
muscle relaxers
and like
just drink a bunch of alcohol because i
thought it was enough because i was
friends with a girl that was
a wild time honey and she said that
would work
and it didn't i
i just remember waking up to me throwing
up a bunch of yellow and then like my um
um the police filing like a missing
person's report on me but
it was fine that was one of the wildest
times of my life and then like
other than that i haven't actually tried
to like
do that until i don't know how long ago
that was made like three years ago
okay
but and that's what's so [ __ ] up
because compared to like the first time
i tried that
the the first time i tried that i was
scared and i was sad
but the second time i wasn't it wasn't
sad or scared i felt like actually just
so good
i remember his name oh my god um tom i
think tom tom campbell
tom
it's big truth here just google big toe
theory and he gave me peace about that
and i don't say he urged me to commit
suicide because he didn't but it was
like
my my second attempt
after i was watching his videos i was
like
girl
i don't i didn't feel it was just like
okay and i was doing a lot of mushrooms
too so i was like
i don't know i just felt like i was not
sad and it's still even when i think of
death now i don't feel
sad i feel like people should have a
right to
be able to do what they want without
you know like i feel like people have
the right to do what they want but
what's what's been the best time of your
life
well i guess
i mean i don't i feel like i'm never
really like
um
well i feel like good like i do like i
feel like
i do feel good i'm just drunk
i was like
i i feel good like i feel like
just like i don't have the life
experience where it's like i feel like
wow i love it here i i'm
having
the time of my life which is okay i feel
like
not bad about that i feel like like i
never feel sorry for myself i feel like
it's
like just every human is important here
on earth to like have some sort we're
not going to understand it no human will
ever will until we die then maybe we'll
be like
unless god is ratchet and
see
we might never know maybe life is
actually meaningless
that's just a total mindful but it's
like i like in general like
in general i would say that i feel
happy you know but not
wow i love it
i'm having the time of my life i would
say
i'm happy in the sense where i'm like
um
grateful to have good health and
some people some people that love me and
like animals that love me and like i
discovered art and that helped me a lot
so it's like i feel like
i'm just
don't think oh wow life is the time of
my life but i feel in
general grateful and happy
which of your body parts are you
proudest of
i love
i love my tits i love my tits i could
literally like
like i love it
that's why nice that's convenient
i love it i love my kids
i love everything that's the thing i'm i
really i don't feel like i'm
narcissistic but i just
i
i'm just i love my mind and i love
everything i've done i chose to do it to
myself and i love it and just like feel
very
just like like i don't view myself even
as anything sexuality and myself as like
a really cool human being
so it's like i was like so i just love
it do you think you're misunderstood by
many people girl
that's why it's like a total mind [ __ ]
because
like i don't blame them it it's weird i
don't like it's just
so i don't even get offended or mad
because it's i can
barely wrap my mind about a lot of my
human experiences but it's like
that's just what it is but i feel
in general
i just feel good and if i had a message
to the world i would just want the world
to just you know
do
live your life for you
do things in your life that
makes you happy if you feel like
kind of insecure about doing some stuff
and you're over thinking about other
people and stuff don't
i'm oh
is it
do it like if you
if okay then try it and then if you do
it and then it's just affecting you
daily then don't but like and i do think
like being educated is important i do
like that for them but also
i don't just try to be a good human when
you wake up like that's it and just if
you feel like being an ass i think
really mean [ __ ] about people all the
[ __ ] time
you think i don't walk by people i'm
like
girl i do all the time but like like the
way the mind like you just you keep some
stuff in your head that is not good and
then you just
gradually train your mind to suppress
like [ __ ] up thoughts and then it's
just
a matter of just intention just live
your life trying to be a good human and
no that's great
that's a great way to go through life
i love that that's wonderful i like that
like that's all that matters but it
seems so complicated like in my mind
it's like it's so logical but it's not
no it's easy
it's not wild though like
thank you mary
you're fascinating
ew i'm sad that i was crying on there
you